This is I've acquired I'm here for the Brooklyn public libraries our streets are stories. For
am I here says I Her library some of the members of the site are singing.
Today it's every ninety two thousand and sixty and I'm here with Rose
GORDON So growing boy I was born in Brooklyn New
York in a regional hospital.
On Fourth
Avenue. In Bay Ridge. I guess Bay Ridge section.
I was the only one of three of my three siblings that
was. That was born in a hospital and they always
kidded me about the fact that they weren't and I was
and but I always had a laugh over it. That I was the rich rich
rich
daughter. And my mother
had. The two boys in a home and I get an
apartment house. On Fourth Avenue in Brooklyn.
And she had a done by but big was taking care of by a midwife.
And after the midwife left the the women and mothers on the block used to take
care for the patient. By cooking them food for the family. They just
to come to the fire escape.
To visit. And to give them anything they need it.
And
that's how we lived we didn't know of any other way but helping each other.
we had.
We were poor and we didn't even realize we were
poor we had we let my brother and I always say we didn't even
know we were poor we had a good
time and then we had a grating. By the stores.
And it was a grating and it has had holes in it and used to find my
mother's
mop. And put a piece of gum on the end of it and
get the quarters. And dimes and nickels out of the year and of
these on on the stick. I pray that it was back again if it didn't fall off
you could run to the candy
store with your fries.
I don't
call her shoes was always popular and sometimes I
get a so according to how much. Sometimes I get a pickle from the delicatessen.
They had a stag pickle
barrel and.
And I say to my mother Can I have a nickel for a pickle.
And we had that was my.
Remembrance of my block but then we had Coney Island. And we
had the steeplechase I don't know if anyone spoke of the steeplechase. Where
you would have a
circular punch card. And then she would go on the ride they
would that was all rides kinds of rides in there. And you had to
pay to go in and they had. The blow blow
up. Apparatus that when a woman lived in they used a
whiskered small sleigh then.
Would blow up your skirt throughout
then and then you had your choice of. Rides I had something
called the iron horse in a slide and the boat ride. They
had just went around until you found something like. Had your
card punched. And went on the. And when on the
ride it
was it was great fun.
When we all look for the day we go there we had certain
places to stay on Coney Island beach.
Like as a teenager as you grew up and became a
teenager teenagers would meet in a certain area on the beach.
That was like our of
spot.
And. We never got into any trouble let the kids who are in today need
to with swimming and. So always other into the water and on lap.
But the staple Chase was one of my
favorites
and psychoanalysts a favorite of Brooklyn Dodgers was a favorite.
That found at one point I husband and his brother found a hole in the
fence of Ebbets Field.
And they used to cope with it for nothing. I
used to sneak in. And watched era the beloved Dodgers who.
Who deserted
us. And I don't know do we have any questions for
me where you're
from they were born in Sicily and in Italy but the
ball the ball of those two.
And. We went to an interest
and instead trees dot com and we found out the town that we
were. That my parents came from.
And but we couldn't find much information so the girls
are thinking of taking a trip. My two daughters go I
can't really go anymore because like you I wanted to go.
But they wanted to see the
place. And. I went
to P.S. ninety four here in
Brooklyn. And went to bed I would try school in Brooklyn.
I didn't go any higher than that our whole idea at that time was to find
a guy and get married that was our
graduates.
And we used to write his name all over our book. And.
A loose leaf book we used to write
on and. It wasn't a big thing with me
I didn't. I was a tomboy. I was the Klein grooves and.
Play ring only Rio I don't know if anyone has heard of
that
and you would say I declare war we had a circle with all
countries in it. And we would say I declare war on France. And that
person had to pick up
the. Object and trying to get you the one that you declared that
declared boiler war on him.
So we have would stayed on the block and we had a very nice
time. And the girls always did composition.
Played composition songs like mining. My name
is Alice and I have a boy that had a start with an A anything it
had anything with an AI I eat. A lot of apples that will
be ten.
And that's it for me as a question to have. You know
what I did do after.
Oh after high school I'm going to.
I went to work in a bank on Fifth Avenue final one fifth
Avenue across from the New York library.
And.
My husband was in the Korean War. But he was an
active in the war he was an M.P. stations in Germany.
And as they all said to me I was a young girl of course. Why don't you write to
this young man he's asking us to write to him. I said I can't be bothered
them to besiege you know having a good time yeah. So
they fell he came back and I met him in the
bank. And we are married when I read.
And they gave us a nice cry Don't shower.
We used to. Even the Automat around the corner way would put your money in.
This window. And food would be nearing you'd put the amount that
they asked for. And come out and have a piece of pie and a cup of
coffee. And then that's about it when we were married
then I had to leave the bank because I could mark in the same place.
That he was.
But they always tease me about.
He they always
tease me about not wanting to write to him and then end up marrying
him I was you can work in
saying what's
the matter of security. That you know maybe you would ask me to do
something are they were says the purity
thing and. Yeah. So I went to a different branch
says Yeah. Your Hold on.
Yes ma'am.
So what is it about.
Flava ball.
If very nice place to live. Everyone used to take care of themselves
or any a lot of men were out of jobs years ago when the women used to.
And the women used to other families just to help them. Most of them worked in
the Navy
Yard. Very when the ships coming
in and loaning them
and. And their families husband women didn't work
of course they took care of the children. And if a family man was out
of work. Other women on the block used to say oh I
made extra beef stew do you and I and everybody
this isn't something that helps
them and help them get through the period when he didn't have
a job which I thought I think there's a fair test that things to do.
They took care. Point another.
And then. That was just nice people I used to have to get a new
store on my block. Listen to wish chronic pain to store an attack.
And they were both made if you went to one. So
you say
Rose you don't come to me. I said No I went and did something in
Miss miss what's in there. That I wanted but it gave me a job when I
had been down there
eight o'clock in the morning.
They used to sell the newspaper saw to the sidewalk where they would be tied up.
I used to clip them and they had a new stand outside
oh about a little bigger than that this. And ice to put them out on
the newsstand. And he used to give me free candy or.
I don't know if I receive money but I used to get candy and he and the only
phone my while my mother wanted to
call someone called receive a
call he would send a kid to ring my mother's Bell My mother used after
the time of this.
And that's about all of you if you have more questions I was wonderful I
love
that boy. Come upon me Alan especially.
Used to have lies the time say of
Nathan Nathan finest. Good friend Phyllis good.
Good food they even used to have dropped some rolls that that time
sometimes. Yeah. And.
That's about it.
Any other question why are you for that I can
see. Why my part of the text because I'd love to
say
yeah. I don't know how talented I am but it doesn't matter and
when you join the diagnosing as a. To the library would just a very very
very sweet thing to do.
For people my age and younger and older. If you like to sing you
just walk through the door and they. And they take you to sit down and join them and
we have a we make friends and we have a very good time.
We go out to eat sometime and.
And that's about it may need every Friday.
And I just love it says.
My neighbor.
Used to come before me. And when I lost my best friend she
encouraged me to come with
her she said wanted to come to the Dayak the singers and.
You'll enjoy yourself because I used to come around the yard in the.
So that
set of thank you for joining us because.